so today I'm going to show you a remedy
that can very quickly
get rid of the Cravings to not just
alcohol but sugar as well so when
someone craves alcohol what is it that
they're looking for well it's has
something to do with reducing
stress anxiety pressure in the body
right it gives them the sense of relief
same thing with sugar sugar makes people
feel better right but it comes with a
little bit of a package which I'm not
going to get into in this video but I'm
going to tell you one simple thing that
you can take to very quickly get rid of
the Cravings especially if you're in the
situation where you're basically
addicted and that substance is something
called L glutamine okay but it's very
important to understand why L-glutamine
will work for this problem now glutamine
is the most abundant amino acid in your
entire body okay and glutamine turns
into glutamate which is the most
abundant neurotransmitter in your brain
and when we think about
neurotransmitters you probably think
about serotonin dopamine things like
that people don't think of glutamate as
a neurotransmitter but it is it's the
most abundant neurotransmitter in your
brain and without getting in too deep
into the woods glutamate is an
excitatory neurotransmitter okay others
are inhibitory and there is a problem
when you have too much glutamate it can
create kind of a Toxic effect actually
giving you anxiety depression insomnia
things like that but the way that it
really works in the brain there's a
whole system going on and so the
glutamate actually helps support an
inhibitory neurotransmitter called Gaba
which is like the brakes so when your
body is in a healthy State you have this
nice balance of the accelerator and the
brakes so you really don't have to worry
about it but the amino acid L-glutamine
actually increases
gluconeogenesis that's the production of
new sugar so that amino acid actually
can very easily and quickly turn into
glucose and feed your brain cells and
make them happy without the side effects
of like sugar your insulin will not
Spike because it's kind coming through a
different pathway it's coming from an
amino acid not a stray glucose so it's a
quick way to supply energy to the brain
without all the bad stuff satisfying the
lack of fuel changing your mood very
quickly reducing stress pressure anxiety
and decreasing the need for alcohol or
sugar but glutamate does a lot more than
just what I mentioned it also is the
precursor for glutathione which is the
main antioxidant in your liver it
supports the cells of your intestines
helping prevent leaky gut it is a very
essential precursor to help heal the
body when you're going through an
infection
recovery surgery trauma or stress you
need more glutamine in your body now
what causes a deficiency is alcohol so
alcohol blocks this glutamine okay and
all the good effects that come with it
you can imagine if you're drinking on a
regular basis over a period of time
you're just depleting your glutamine and
glutamate and setting yourself up for
all sorts of problems down the road now
the other thing that causes a major
deficiency of glutamine is chronic
stress when you're under chronic stress
you actually get an increase of
glutamate in a part of your brain called
the hippocampus creating all sorts of
problems with memory and learning
but in the frontal cortex we have a
decrease of glutamate and that's going
to affect your attention you'll probably
develop attention deficit problems in
another part of your brain it's called
the amygdala which is very similar to
your adrenal gland because it it's
everything to do with stress and stress
responses but it's in your brain you
have a decrease of glutamate from
chronic stress in the amygdala giving
you the sensation of anxiety another
thing that can cause a deficiency of
glutamine is over training like in
exercising too much without letting
yourself recover having trauma any
trauma surgery injury things like that a
chronic infection and let's say you're
just not consuming enough glutamine in
your diet now what foods are high in
glutamine well you have beef chicken
fish eggs dairy okay you also have a
cabbage dark leafy green vegetables kale
spinach parsley if you want to get rid
of the cravings for alcohol and sugar
okay of course I'm assuming you've
already tried the ketogenic diet and
intermittent fasting which will
ultimately correct it but you might need
something to handle the Cravings quickly
so you can actually do the ketogenic
plan and so I recommend taking between
two to five grams per day so by taking
this in a supplement form making sure
you're eating the foods high in
glutamine which basically is a ketogenic
diet you can really start to pull
yourself out of this situation there are
other things that can also help this
whole glutamate cycle regular exercise
without over training getting enough
sleep and doing whatever you can to
reduce stress will greatly help and the
less alcohol you drink the less
deficiency you'll have now to ultimately
fully correct this problem you need to
be on the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet with intermittent fasting
and for that information
check this video out right here